("Empire State of Mind" by Alicia Keys)
- Wait wait wait.
What's a fandango?
- It's a movie service.
- Yeah, okay.
- My neck hurts.
- No, stop it.
Ow, ow.
- Then pull over!
- Yeah, we've been driving
for like three hours!
- I told you we're not stopping!
- You're not my real dad!
- I wish that I wasn't!
- I miss mom.
- Oh wait.
- Oh wait, oh.
- What?
- You nasty.
That's some Cosby shit.
♪ Ole, ole, ole ♪
- Chris.
Chris, stop eating my muffins!
- I didn't have breakfast, I'm hungry!
- No no no, it's "thunderchief," guys.
- It's "done with sheep."
- It's "underneath."
- No no no.
- It's actually "hunger Keith."
- Get out of here, Keith.
Get out of here!
- Get out of our videos,
stinker!
- You can't be in every video,
Keith!
- I wanna be in the band!
I wanna be in the band!
- Get out of here!
Oh!
(Eugene coughs)
- Fuck, Chris!
- There's only one thing
that would make this better.
- What?
- Sexually.
- Gross, Allison, let's get out of here.
- Ew, you smell like a douche.
- What, like Axe body spray?
- No, like an actual douche.
(Chris chokes)
♪ Having the time of your life ♪
♪ Ooh, see that girl ♪
♪ Watch that scene ♪
♪ Kicking the dancing queen ♪
- [Chris] I'm still--
(Chris screams)
♪ Ah-Ah-Ah ♪
- [Chris] I'm still alive!
- Ew, creep!
Oh my god, I love hugs!
- I'm sorry about all of that.
- [Man] Take me back.
(Eugene chuckles)
- I'm Cher, bitch.
- [Men] What?
- That means granny panties.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Your improvs suck.
- [Man] This is a battle.
- [Eugene And Chris]
Alex Lewis specifically.
- How did they know?
- [Eugene And Chris] Stop dancing.
- This is my nightmare.
- [Eugene And Chris] Seriously, stop.
- Nope.
- No, I.
Yup!
♪ I really don't think
I'm strong enough, no ♪
- Let's go shopping, momma needs halos.
- Ooh, a lawyer?
- Yeah, passed her bar.
- They make a lot of money.
- Smart and pretty, you should go for it.
- Okay, I will.
- Hey, who sings that song?
- Uh, Chris Brown?
- Ooh.
- Ooh, yeah.
That's definitely misheard.
- No, this song's about
respecting women, right guys?
- Yeah, it's not if Chris Brown sings it.
- I think I know Chris Brown.
Oh, who's the little baby!
Who I really are?
♪ I sing-- ♪
- That's?
- Who I really are, yeah.
- Oh, that's a good misheard lyric.
- Yeah.
- No, those are the
real lyrics.
♪ I been drinking ♪
♪ I been drinking flippin'
dippin' bippin' Scottie Pippin ♪
- Well that doesn't make any
grammatical sense at all.
- I mean, it's the song, so.
- Ah, that's stupid.
(heavy breathing)
- Oh my god, when Kylo Ren, huh?
- That was crazy!
- Hey, hey, spoilers!
Spoilers!
- Sorry.
- Sorry, sorry.
- Who do you think Rey's parents are?
- Okay, so I have a theory--
- La la la la la!
- Digimon are the champions!
- But I'm horny.
- Well, it's winter.
- Should we go?
- No!
You stay!
- I'm bored.
- I'm hungry.
- This job sucks.
(Eugene farts)
- Oh my god.
Oh, gee, that's.
They're real carrots!
- Oh my god!
- Again, again!
(Eugene farts)
Oh, Jesus!
- No!
This relationship is broken!
- We really should get out of here.
- No!
You will stay and sing!
- [Chris] What?
(chicken screams)
- Oh god!
- Holy shit!
No!
Gross.
Fine.
- Did you just say a dude?
I want a divorce!
- Please welcome to the
1989 world tour stage
my very best friends!
(crowd cheering)
Ashly Perez, Quinta Bruson,
and Ella Mielniczenko!
- Hey!
- Don't hit me Eugene.
- Sorry.
- All right.
- Okay!
- Oh god!
- Oh, sorry, ass carrots all over you.
(Eugene farts)
Oh, another one!
Whoo, I ain't worried either, up top!
- Yeah buddy!
- Boom.
- Oh.
- Oh, another one.
- Bam!
- Oh.
(shovel bangs)
- Did he leave?
- Too soon.
- Whoa, whoa, whoa, Chris,
that's not misheard,
it's a Caribbean accent.
- Oh, a Jamaican accent!
(Chris imitating an accent)
- No, it's not Jamaican, it's Bajan.
- Bacon!
Bacon!
- No, Chris, you're being
a little racist.
- I thought we voted we were
okay with racism this year?
(Eugene sighs)
- Can you guys hurry up?
(item buzzes)
- Is that what I think?
- Oh, sorry, I don't do drugs.
- Yeah, Chris, don't be gross.
- Pizza?
- Oh, I don't like
pizza either.
- What?
- What the fuck?
- Leave!
- Get the fuck out of here!
- Get out of here!
- Jesus fucking Christ.
♪ Players ♪
(Eugene farts)
- Oh my god.
Wow.
Oh my, wait, can you?
(Eugene farts)
Oh, he's still got it!
- Ew.
- He's still got it!
Your only butthole.
A tremendous butthole, a huge butthole.
Buttholes love me.
Waist down she's a masterpiece,
waist down she's a masterpiece,
Waist up she's a four.
I wouldn't, I wouldn't.
(Eugene vomits)
- You know Wrath of Khan
is actually the best Star Trek film.
- No no no no, it's like,
wraith, like a Rolls Royce.
(Chris chuckles)
- No, wraiths are from
Lord of the Rings.
Nice chat.
- Nerd
She didn't know what a nazgul was guys.
(everyone laughs)
- There are no more girls at this party.
- Does anyone want an Asian baby?
- Uh, I'm White I'd love an Asian baby
- Great, have mine.
- (laughs)
- Thanks.
- Ooh, I am the new Brangelina.
- AH, oh,
oh my god.
- Innocent dancing for your song
- You don't know what
this song's about, do you?
- Yeah, it's like dancing.
- No it's when you get like
(bleep)
that's what a wrist icicle is.
- I gotta, start going
to church again, I think.
(Chris chokes)
- Help us
- Oh, come on guys that's too literal, God
- He left us again.
- It's still too soon
(Eugene chokes)
- Oh God, oh God, Jesus.
No more. No more.
Let's move on, I hate this.
- (Chris) No, why! Why
do we have to do these?!
- (Eugene) Bye 2016, see ya later